thank you all for having me it's
exciting to be here uh one of my
favorite things is talking about what is
going on inside neural networks or at
least what we what we're trying to
figure out is going on inside neural
networks so it's it's always fun to chat
about that
um
oh gosh i have to figure out how to how
to do things okay can i
what i i want okay there we go now now
we are advancing slides that seems wrong
um so i think interpretability means
lots of different things to different
people um it's a very a very broad term
and and people mean all sorts of
different things by it
um and so i wanted to talk just briefly
about uh the kind of interpretability
that i i spend my time thinking about um
which is what i'd call mechanistic
interpretability so
um most of my work actually has not been
on language models or on rnn's or
transformers but um on understanding
vision confidence and and trying to
understand how do the parameters in
those models actually map to algorithms
so you can like think of the parameters
of a neural network as being like a
compiled computer program and and the
neurons are kind of like variables or
registers and somehow there's there
there are these these complex computer
programs that are are embedded in those
weights and we'd like to turn them back
in to computer programs that that humans
can understand it's a kind of kind of
reverse engineering problem
um
and so this is this is kind of a
fun example that we found where there
was a car neuron and you could actually
see that um you know that we have the
car neuron and it's constructed from
like a wheel neuron
and it looks for in the case of the
wheel neuron it's looking for for the
wheels on the bottom and those are
positive weights and it doesn't want to
see them on top so there's negative
weights there and there's also a window
neuron it's looking for the windows on
the top and and not on the bottom and so
what we're actually seeing there right
is it's an algorithm it's an algorithm
that goes and turns um you know it's
it's just it's you know saying you know
well cars is has wheels on the bottom
and windows on the top and chrome in the
middle um and that's that's actually
like just the the strongest neurons for
that and so we're actually seeing a
meaningful algorithm and that's that's
not an exception that's that's sort of
the the general story that if you're
willing to go and look at neural neural
network weights and you're willing to
invest a lot of energy and trying to
first engineer them there's there's
meaningful algorithms written in the
weights waiting for you to find them
um and there's a bunch of reasons i
think that's an interesting thing to
think about one is you know just no one
knows how to go and do the things that
neural networks can do like no one knows
how to write a computer program that can
accurately classify imagenet let alone
you know the language modeling tasks
that we're doing no one knows how to
like directly write a computer program
that can do the things that gpd3 does
and yet somehow breaking descent is able
to go and discover a way to do this and
i want to know what's going on i want to
know you know how what is it discovered
that it can do in in these systems
there's another reason why i think this
is important which is uh is safety so
you know if we if we want to go and use
these systems in in places where they
have big effect on the world and
i think a question we need to ask
ourselves is you know what what happens
when these models have have
unanticipated failure modes failure
modes we didn't know to go and test for
or to look for to check for
how can we how can we discover those
things especially if they're they're
really pathological failure modes so the
models in some sense deliberately doing
something that we don't want well the
only way that i really see that we we
can do that is if we can get to a point
where we really understand what's going
on inside these systems
um so that's another reason that i'm
interested in this
now uh actually doing interpersonally on
language models and transformers it's
new to me i um before this year i spent
like eight years working on trying
reverse engineer confidence uh and
vision models um and so the ideas in
this talk um are are new things that
i've been thinking about with my
collaborators um and we're still
probably a month or two out maybe maybe
longer from publishing them um and this
is also the first public talk that i've
given on it so uh you know the things
i'm going to talk about um they made
they're i think honestly still a little
bit confused for me um and definitely
are going to be confused in my
articulation of them so if i say things
that are confusing um you know please
feel free to ask me questions there
might be some points for me to go
quickly because there's a lot of content
um but definitely at the end i will be
available for a while to chat about the
stuff um
and uh yeah also i apologize um if uh if
i'm unfamiliar with zoom and make make
mistakes um but
uh yeah so um with that said uh let's
dive in
um so i wanted to start with a mystery
um before we go and try to actually dig
into you know what's going on inside
these models um i wanted to motivate it
by a really strange piece of discover of
behavior that we discovered and and
wanted to understand
um
uh and by the way i should say all this
work is um uh you know is done with my
my colleagues anthropic and especially
my colleagues catherine and nelson
okay so on to the mystery
um i think probably the the most
interesting and most exciting thing
about um about transformers is their
ability to do in-context learning or
sometimes people call it meta-learning
um you know the gp3 paper uh goes and
and describes things as uh you know uh
language models are few shot learners
like there's lots of impressive things
about gp3 but they choose to focus on
that and you know now everyone's talking
about prompt engineering um and um
andrei caprathi was was joking about how
you know software 3.0 was designing the
prompt and so the ability of language
models of these these large transformers
to respond to their context and learn
from their context and change their
behavior and response to their context
and you know really seems like probably
the most surprising and striking and
remarkable thing about them
um
and
uh some of my my colleagues previously
published a paper that has a trick in it
that i i really love which is so we're
all used to looking at learning curves
you train your model and you you know as
your model trains the loss goes down
sometimes it's a little bit
discontinuous but it goes down
another thing that you can do is you can
go and take a fully trained model and
you can go and ask you know as we go
through the context you know as we go we
predict the first token and then the
second token and the third token we get
better at predicting each token because
we have more information to go and
predict it on so you know the first the
first con token the the loss should be
the the entropy of the unigrams and then
the next token should be the entry of
the biograms and it falls
but it keeps falling
and it keeps getting better
and
in in some sense that's our that's the
model's ability to go and predict to go
and do in-context learning the ability
to go and predict um you know to be
better at predicting later tokens than
you are predicting early tokens that is
that is in some sense a mathematical
definition of what it means to be good
at this magical in-context learning or
meta-learning that these models can do
and so that's kind of cool because that
gives us a a way to go and look at
whether models are good at in-context
learning
yeah if i could just ask the question
like a clarification question
please when you say learning there are
no actual parameters
that is the remarkable thing about
in-context learning right so yeah indeed
we traditionally think about neural
networks as learning over the course of
training by going and modifying their
parameters but somehow models appear to
also be able to learn in some sense um
if you give them a couple examples in
their context they can then go and do
that later in their context even though
no parameters changed and so it's it's
some kind of quite different different
notion of learning as you're as you're
gesturing that
uh
okay i think that's making more sense so
i mean could you also just describe in
context learning in this case as
conditioning as in like conditioning on
the first five tokens of a ten token
sentence
pretty cool tokens yeah i think the
reason that people sometimes think about
this as in context learning or meta
learning is that you can do things where
you like actually take a training set
and you embed the training set in your
context like if you just two or three
examples and then suddenly your model
can go and do do this task and so you
can do fuchsia learning by embedding
things in the context yeah the formal
setup is that you're you're just
conditioning on on on this context and
it's just that somehow this this ability
like this thing like there's there's
some sense you know for a long time
people were
were
i mean i i guess really the history of
this is uh
we started to get good at neural
networks learning right um and we could
we could go and train language uh train
vision models and language models that
could do all these remarkable things but
then people started to be like well you
know these systems are they take so many
more examples than humans do to go and
learn how can we go and fix this and we
had all these ideas about metal learning
develop where we wanted to go and and
train models
explicitly to be able to learn from a
few examples and people developed all
these complicated schemes and then the
like truly like absurd thing about about
transformer language models is without
any effort at all we get this for free
that you can go and just give them a
couple examples in their context and
they can learn in their context to go
and do new things um i think that was
like like that was in some sense the
like most striking thing about the gpd3
paper
um
and so uh this this yeah this ability to
go and have the just conditioning on a
context go and give you you know new
abilities for free and and the ability
to generalize to new things is in some
sense the the most yeah and to me the
most striking and shocking thing about
about transformer language models
that makes sense i mean i guess
from my perspective
i'm trying to square like
the notion of learning in this case
with you know if you or i were given a
prompt of like one plus one equals two
two plus three equals five
as the sort of few shot set up and then
somebody else put you know like five
plus three equals and we had to fill it
out in that case i wouldn't say that
we've learned arithmetic because we
already sort of knew it but rather we're
just sort of conditioning on the prompt
to know what it is that we should then
generate right
uh but it seems to me like that's
yeah i think that's on the spectrum
though because you can you can also go
and give like completely nonsensical
problems where the model would never
have seen um see like mimic this
function and give a couple examples of
the function and the model's never seen
it before and i can go and do that later
in the context um and i think i think
what you did learn um in a lot of these
cases you might not have you might have
um
you might not have learned arithmetic
like you might have had some innate
faculty for arithmetic that you're using
but you might have learned oh okay right
now we're doing arithmetic problems
um
got it in the case this is i agree that
there's like an element of semantics
here um yeah you know this is helpful
though just to clarify exactly sort of
what the
yeah what you remember
thank you for watching of course
so something that's i think really
striking about all of us
um
is well okay so we we've talked about
how we can we can sort of look at the
learning curve and we can also look at
this in context learning curve but
really those are just two slices of a
two-dimensional uh space so like the the
in some sense the more fundamental thing
is how good are we at producing the nth
token at a different given point in
training
and something that you'll notice if you
if you look at this and so when we when
we talk about the loss curve we're just
talking about if you average over this
dimension
if you if you like average like this and
and project on to the the training step
that's that's your loss curve um and um
if you the thing that we are calling the
incontext learning curve is just this
line um
uh yeah this this line uh down the end
here
um
and something that's that's kind of
striking is there's there's this
discontinuity in it um like there's this
point where where you know the model
seems to get radically better in a very
very short time step span at going and
predicting late tokens
so it's not that different in early time
steps but in late time steps suddenly
you get better
and a way that you can make this more
striking is you can you can take the
difference in in your ability to put the
50th token and your ability to predict
the 500 token you can subtract from the
the the 500th token the 50th token loss
and what you see
um is that over the course of trading
you know you're you're you're not very
good at this and you get a little bit
better and then suddenly
you have this cliff and then you never
get better than the difference between
these at least never gets better so the
model gets better at predicting things
but its ability to go and predict late
tokens over early tokens never gets
better
and so there's in the span of just a few
hundred steps in training the model has
gotten radically better at its ability
to go and and do this kind of in context
learning
and so you might ask you know what's
going on at that point
um and this is just one model but um
well so first of all it's worth noting
this isn't a small a small change and so
um
that you can we don't think about this
very often but you know often we just
look at loss goes more like did the
model do better than another model or
worse than another model but um you can
you can think about this as in terms of
gnats and that are are you know it's
just the information theoretic quantity
in that um and you can convert that into
bits and so like one one way you can
interpret this is it's it's something
roughly like you know the model 0.4 nas
is about 0.5 bits is about uh like every
other token the model gets to go and
sample twice um and pick the better one
it's actually it's even stronger than
that that's sort of an underestimate of
how big a deal going and getting better
by 0.4 an ounces so this is like a real
big difference in the model's ability to
go and predict late tokens
um and we can visualize this in
different ways we can we can also go and
ask you know how much better are we
getting at going and predicting later
tokens and look at the derivative and
then we we can see very clearly that
there's there's some kind of
discontinuity in that derivative at this
point and we can take the second
derivative then and we can um with well
derivative with respect to training and
now we see that there's like there's
very very clearly this this line here so
something in just the span of a few
steps a few hundred steps is is causing
some big change and we have some kind of
phase change going on
um and this is true across model sizes
um
uh you can you can actually see it a
little bit in the loss curve and there's
this little bump here and that
corresponds to the point where you have
this you have this change we we actually
could have seen in the lost curve
earlier too it's it's this bump here
excuse me so so we have this phase
change going on and there's a i think a
really tempting theory to have which is
that somehow whatever you know there's
some this this change in the model's
output and its behaviors and it's in a
in a in in these sort of outward facing
properties corresponds presumably to
some kind of change in the algorithms
that are running inside the model so if
we observe this big phase change
especially in a very small window um in
in the model's behavior presumably
there's some change in the circuits
inside the model that is driving that
at least that's a you know a natural
hypothesis so
um if we want to ask that though we need
to go and be able to understand you know
what are the algorithms that's running
inside the model how can we turn the
parameters in the model back into those
algorithms so that's going to be our
goal
um now it's going to recover us require
us to cover a lot of ground um in a
relatively short amount of time so i'm
going gonna go a little bit quickly
through the next section and i will
highlight sort of the the key takeaways
and then i will be very happy um to go
and uh you know explore any of this in
as much depth i'm free for another hour
after this call um and just happy to
talk in as much depth as people want
about the details of this
so
um it turns out this phase change
doesn't happen in a one layer attention
only transformer and it does happen in a
two-layer attention-only transformer so
if we could understand a one-layer
attenuate transformer and a two layer
only attention potentially transformer
that might give us a pretty big clue as
to what's going on
um
so we're attention only we're also going
to leave out layer and biases to
simplify things so you know you one way
you could describe a attention only
transformer
is we're going to embed our tokens
and then we're going to apply a bunch of
attention heads and add them into the
residual stream and then apply our
unembedding and that'll give us our
logits
and we can go and write that out as
equations if we want multiplied by an
embedding matrix
apply attention heads
and then compute the logics from the
unembedding
um
and the part here that's a little tricky
is understanding the attention ads and
this might be a somewhat conventional
way of describing attention and it
actually kind of obscures a lot of the
structure of attentionnets and i think
that oftentimes it's we we make
attention heads more more complex than
they are we sort of hide the interesting
structure
so what is this saying let's say you
know for every token compute a value
back a value vector and then go and mix
the value vectors according to the
attention matrix and then project them
with the output matrix back into the
residual string
um so there's there's another notation
which you could think of this as a as
using tensor products or using um using
uh
well i guess there's a few left and
right multiplying there's a few ways you
can interpret this but um
i'll just sort of try to explain what
this notation means um
so this means
for every you know x or our residual
string we have a vector for every single
token
and this means go and multiply
independently the vector for each token
by wv so compute the value vector for
every token
this one on the other hand means notice
that it's now on the a is on the left
hand side it means go and go and
multiply
the
attention matrix or go and go into
linear combinations of the values value
vectors so don't don't change the value
vectors you know point wise but go and
mix them together according to the
attention pattern create a weighted sum
and then again independently for every
position go and apply the output matrix
and you can apply the distributive
property to this and it just reveals
that actually it didn't matter that you
did the attention sort of in the middle
you could have done the attention at the
beginning you could have done it at the
end um that's that's independent um and
the thing that actually matters is
there's this wvwo matrix that describes
what it's really saying is you know
wvw describes what information the
attention head reads from each position
and how it writes it to its destination
whereas a describes which tokens we read
from and write to
um and that's that's kind of getting
more the fundamental structure and
attention an attention head goes and
moves information from one position to
another and the process of of which
position gets moved from and two is
independent from what information gets
moved
and if you rewrite your transformer that
way
well first we can go and write uh the
sum of attention heads just as as in
this form
um and then we can uh go and write that
as the the entire layer by going and
adding an identity
and if we go and plug that all in to our
transformer and go and expand
um we we have to go and multiply
everything through we get this
interesting equation and so we get this
one term this corresponds to just the
path directly through the residual
stream
and it's going to want to store uh
bigram statistics it's just you know all
i guess is the previous token and tries
to predict the next token
and so it gets to try and predict uh try
to store bi-gram statistics and then for
every attention head we get this matrix
that says okay well for we have the
attention pattern so it looks that
describes which token looks at which
token and we have this matrix here which
describes how for every possible token
you could attend to
how it affects the logics and that's
just a table that you can look at it
just says you know for for this
attention head if it looks at this token
it's going to increase the probability
of these tokens in a one layer attention
only transformer that's all there is
um yeah so this is just just the
interpretation i was describing
um
and another thing that's worth noting is
this
the according to this the attention on
the transformer is linear if you fix the
attention pattern now of course it's the
attention pattern isn't fixed but
whenever you even have the opportunity
to go and make something linear linear
functions are really easy to understand
and so if you can fix a small number of
things and make something linear that's
actually
a lot of leverage
okay
um
and yeah we can talk about how the
attention pattern is computed as well
um you if you expand it out you'll get
an equation like this
and uh notice well i think i think it'll
be easier
okay
the i think the core story though to
take away from all of these is we have
these two matrices that actually look
kind of similar so
this one here
tells you if you attend to a token
how are the logits affected
and it's you can just think of it as a
giant matrix of for every possible token
input token how how is the logic how are
the logics affected
by that token are they made more likely
or less likely
and we have this one which sort of says
how much does every token want to attend
to every other token
um one way that you can you can picture
this is
uh okay that's really there's really
three tokens involved when we're
thinking about an attention head we have
the
token that
we're going to move information to and
that's attending backwards
we have the source token that's going to
get attended to and we have the output
token whose logits are going to be
affected
and you can just trace through this so
you can ask what happens um how does the
the attending to this token affect the
output well first we embed the token
then we multiply by wv to get the value
vector the information gets moved by the
attention pattern
we multiply by wo to add it back into
the residual stream we get hit by the
unembedding and we affect the logits and
that's where that one matrix comes from
and we can also ask you know what
decides you know whether a token gets a
high score when we're when we're
computing the attention pattern and it
just says
you know embed embed the token
turn it into a query embed the other
token turn it into a key
and dot product to them and see you
that's where those those two matrices
come from
so i know that i'm going quite quickly
um
maybe i'll just briefly pause here and
if anyone wants to ask for
clarifications uh this would be a good
time and then we'll actually go and
reverse engineer and and say you know
everything that's going on in a
one-layer pendulum transformer is now in
the palm of our hands
it's a very toy model
you know one actually uses one layer
attention on the transformers but we'll
be able to understand the one layer
attention only transformer
so just to be clear so you're saying
that yes the the
quite key circuit is learning the
attention weights
and like essentially it's responsive
running the sort of attention between
different uh tokens
yeah yeah so
so this this matrix when it yeah you
know all three of those parts are
learned but that's that's what expresses
whether
a attention pattern is yeah that's what
generates the attention patterns gets
run for every pair of tokens and you can
you can you can think of values in that
matrix as just being how much every
token wants to attend to every other
token if it was in the context and we're
we're drawing positional weddings here
so there's a little bit that we're sort
of aligning over there as well but sort
of in in a global sense how much does
every token want to attend every other
token right
and the other circuit like the output
value circuit is
using the attention that's calculated to
guess
like affect the final outputs it's sort
of saying if if the attention head
assume that the attention head attends
to some token so let's set aside the
question of how that gets computed just
assume that it hence to some token how
would it affect the outputs if it
attended to that token
and you can just you can just calculate
that um it's just a big table of values
that says you know for this token
it's going to make this token more
likely this token will make this token
less likely
right okay
and it's completely independent like
it's just two separate matrices they're
they're not you know the the formulas
that might make them seem entangled but
they're actually separate
all right so to me it seems like the
lecture supervision is coming from the
output value circuit and the query key
second seems to be more like
unsupervised kind of thing because
there's no
i mean they're just i think in the sense
that every in in an yeah in a model like
every every neuron is in some sense you
know like
signals is is somehow downstream from
the ultimate the ultimate signal and so
you know the output value signal the
output value circuit is getting more
more direct is perhaps getting more
direct signal correct um but yeah
yes
we will be able to dig into this in lots
of detail in as much detail as you want
uh in a little bit so we can um maybe
i'll push forward and i think also
actually an example of how to use this
reverse engineer one layer model will
maybe make it a little bit more more
motivated
okay so
um just just to emphasize this there's
three different tokens that we can talk
about there's a token that gets attended
to
there's the token that does the
attention which are called the
destination and then there's the token
that gets affected yet it gets the next
token which its probabilities are
affected
um
and so something we can do is notice
that the the only token that connects to
both of these is the token that gets
attended to
so these two are sort of they're they're
bridged
by their their interaction with the
source token so something that's kind of
natural is to
ask for a given source token you know
how does it interact with both of these
so let's let's take for instance the
token perfect
which tokens for one thing we can ask is
which tokens want to attend to perfect
well apparently the tokens that most
want to attend to perfect are are and
looks and is and provides
um so r is the most looks is the next
most and so on
and then when we attempt to perfect and
this is with one one single attention
head so you know it'd be different if we
did a different intention attention ed
it wants to really increase the
probability of perfect and then to a
lesser extent super and absolute and
pure and we can ask you know what what
sequences of tokens are made more likely
by this
this particular
um set of you know this particular set
of things wanting to attend to each
other and becoming more likely well
things are the form
we have our tokens we attended back to
and we have some
some skip of some number of tokens they
don't have to be adjacent but then later
on we see the token r and it attends
back to perfect and increases the
probability of perfect
so you can you can think of these as
being like we're sort of creating
changing the probability of what we
might call might call skip trigrams
where we have you know we skip over a
bunch of tokens in the middle but we're
affecting the probability really of of
trigrams
so perfect our perfect perfect look
super
um we can look at another one so we have
the token large
um these tokens contains using specify
want to go and look back to it and it
increases probability of large and small
and the skip trigrams that are affected
are things like large using large
large contained small
and things like this
um if we see the number two and we
increase the probability of other
numbers and we affect probable tokens or
skipped diagrams like two one two
two
has three
um
now you're you're all in uh in a
technical field so you'll probably
recognize this one we have uh have
lambda and then we see backslash and
then we want to increase the probability
of lambda and sorted and lambda and
operator so it's all fall latex
and it wants to and it's if it sees
lambda it thinks that you know maybe
next time i use a backslash i should go
and put in some latex
math symbol
um
also
same thing for html we see nbsp for
non-breaking space and then we see an
ampersand we want to go and make that
more likely
the takeaway from all this is that a one
layer attenuating transformer is totally
acting on these skip trigrams
um
every everything that it does i mean i
guess it also has this pathway by which
it affects bi-grams but mostly it's just
affecting these skiff trigrams
um and there's lots of them it's just
like these giant tables of skip trigrams
that are made more or less likely
um
there's lots of other fun things that
does sometimes the tokenization will
split up a word in multiple ways so um
like we have indie
well that's that's not a good example we
have like the word pike and then we
we see the the token p and then we
predict ike
um when we predict spikes and stuff like
that um
or
these these ones are kind of fun maybe
they're actually worth talking about for
a second so we see
the token void
and then we see an l and maybe we
predict lloyd
um or r and we predict ralph
and c catherine
and but we'll see in a second then well
yeah we'll come back to that in a sec so
we increase the probability of things
like lloyd's lloyd and lloyd catherine
or pixmap
if anyone's worked with qt
um it's we see pics map and we increase
the probability of um p
xmap again but also
q
canvas um
yeah
but of course there's a problem with
this which is um
it doesn't get to pick which one of
these goes with which one
so if you want to go and make pixmap
pixmap
and pixmap q canvas more probable you
also have to go and create make pixmac
pixmap p canvas
more probable
and if you want to make lloyd lloyd and
lloyd catherine
more probable you also have to make
lloyd cloyd and lloyd lathron
more probable
and so there's actually like bugs that
transformers have like weird at least
and you know and these these really tiny
one-layer attention only transformers
there there's these bugs that you know
they seem weird until you realize that
it's this giant table of skip trigrams
that's that's operating
um
and the the nature of that is that
you're going to be
um
uh yeah you it sort of forces you if you
want to go and do this to go in and also
make some weird predictions
chris
is there a reason why the source tokens
here have a space before the first
character
yes um that's just the i was giving
examples where the tokenization breaks
in a particular way and okay um because
spaces get included in the tokenization
um
when there's a space in front of
something and then there's an example
where the space isn't in front of it
they can get tokenized in different ways
got it cool thanks
great question
um
okay so some just to abstract away some
common patterns that we're seeing i
think um
one pretty common thing is what you
might describe as like d
a b so you're you go and you you see
some token and then you see another
token that might precede that token then
you're like ah probably the token that i
saw earlier is going to occur again
um or sometimes you you predict a
slightly different token so like maybe
maybe an example the first one is two
one two
but you could also do two
has three
and so three isn't the same as two but
it's kind of similar so that's that's
one thing another one is this this
example where you've a token that
something it's tokenized together one
time and that's split apart so you see
the token and then you see something
that might be the first part of the
token and then you predict the second
part
and
i think the thing that's really striking
about this is these are all in some ways
a really crude kind of in context
learning
and and
in particular these models get about 0.1
nouns rather than about 0.4
of incontex learning and they never go
through the phase change so they're
doing some kind of really crude and
context learning and also they're
dedicating almost all their attention
heads to this kind of recruiting context
learning so they're not very good at it
but they're they're they're dedicating
their um their capacity to it
uh i'm noticing that it's 10 37 um
i i want to just check how long i can go
because i maybe i should like super
accelerate because this is
chris uh i think it's fine because like
students are also asking questions in
between such uh you should be good
okay so maybe my plan will be that i'll
talk until like 10 55 or 11 and then if
you want i can go and answer questions
for a while after after that
yeah it works
fantastic
so you can see this as a very crude kind
of in context learning like basically
what we're saying is it's sort of all
this flavor of okay well i saw this
token probably these other tokens the
same token or similar tokens are more
likely to go and occur later and look
this is an opportunity that sort of
looks like i can inject the token that i
saw earlier i'm going to inject it here
and say that it's more likely that's
like that's basically what it's doing
and it's dedicating almost all of its
capacity to that so you know these it's
sort of the opposite of what we thought
with rnn's in the past like used to be
that everyone was like oh you know rnn's
it's so hard to care about long distance
contacts you know maybe we need to go
and like use dams or something no if you
if you train a transformer it dedicates
and you give it a long a long enough
context it's dedicating almost all of
its capacity um to this type of stuff um
just kind of interesting
um there are some attentions which are
more primarily positional um usually we
in the model that i've been training
that has two layer or it's only a one
layer model has twelve attention units
and usually around two or three of those
will become these more positional sort
of shorter term things that do something
more like like local trigram statistics
and then everything else becomes these
skipped programs
um yeah so uh some takeaways from this
uh yeah you can you can understand one
layer eventually transformers in terms
of these ov and qk circuits um
transformers desperately want to do
in-context learning they desperately
desperately desperately want to go and
and look at these long distance contacts
and go and predict things there's just
so much so much entropy that they can go
and reuse out of that
the constraints of a when they are
intentionally transformer force it to
make certain bugs but it wants to do the
right thing
um
and if you freeze the attention patterns
these models are linear
okay
um
a quick aside because so far this type
of work has required us to do a lot of
very manual inspection like we're
walking through these giant matrices but
there's a way that we can escape that we
don't have to use look at these giant
matrices if we don't want to
um we can use eigenvalues and
eigenvectors so recall that an
eigenvalue
and an eigenvector just means that if
you if you multiply that vector by the
matrix um it's equivalent to just
scaling
and
uh often
in my experience those haven't been very
useful for interpretability because
we're usually mapping between different
spaces but if you're mapping onto the
same space either values either vectors
are a beautiful way to think about this
um so we're going to draw them um
on a
a radial plot
um and we're going to have a log
uh radial scale because they're gonna
vary their magnitude's gonna vary in by
many orders of magnitude
um okay so we can just go and you know
our ob circuit maps from tokens to
tokens that's the same vector space and
the input and the output and we can ask
you know what does it mean if we see
eigenvalues of a particular kind well
positive eigenvalues and this is really
the most important part mean copying so
if you have a positive eigenvalue it
means that there's some set of of tokens
where if you if you see them you
increase their probability
and if you have a lot of positive
eigenvalues um you're doing a lot of
copying if you only have positive
eigenvalues everything you do is copying
um now imaginary eigenvalues mean that
you see a token and then you want to go
and increase the probability of
unrelated tokens and finally negative
eigenvalues are anti-copying they're
like if you see this token you make it
less probable in the future
well that's really nice because now we
don't have to go and dig through these
giant matrices that are vocab size by
vocab size we can just look at the
eigenvalues
um and so these are the eigenvalues for
our one layer attention only transformer
and we can see that you know
for
many of these they're almost entirely
positive these events are are sort of
entirely positive these ones are almost
entirely positive and really these ones
are even almost entirely positive and
there's only two
that have a significant number of
imaginary and negative eigenvalues
um and so what this is telling us is
it's just in one picture we can see you
know okay they're really you know
10 out of 12 of these of these attention
heads are just doing copying they just
they just are doing this long distance
you know well i saw a token probably
it's going to occur again type stuff um
that's kind of cool we can we can
summarize it really quickly
okay
um
now the other thing that you can yeah so
this is this is for a second we're gonna
look at a two-layer model in a second
and we'll we'll see that also a lot of
its heads are doing this kind of copying
or stuff they have large positive
eigenvalues
um you can do a histogram like you know
one one thing that's cool is you can
just add up the uh the eigenvalues and
divide them by their absolute values and
you get a number between zero and one
which is like how copying how copying is
just the head or between negative one
and one how copying is just the head you
can just do a histogram you can see oh
yeah almost all the heads are doing
doing lots of copying
you know it's nice to be able to go and
summarize your model you know uh and i
think this is this is sort of like we've
gone for a very bottom-up way and we
didn't start with assumptions about what
model is doing we tried to understand
its structure and then we were able to
summarize it in useful ways and now
we're able to go and say something about
it
um now another thing you might ask is
what what do the the eigenvalues of the
qk circuit mean and in our example so
far they haven't been that they wouldn't
have been that interesting but in a
minute they will be and so i'll briefly
describe what they mean a positive
eigenvalue would mean you want to attend
to the same tokens
and imagine your eigenvalue and this is
what you would mostly see in our models
we've seen so far means you want to go
in and attend to a unrelated or
different token
and a negative eigenvalue would mean you
want to avoid attending to the same
triplet
so that will be relevant in a second
um yes so those are going to mostly be
useful to think about in in multi-layer
potentially transformers when we kind of
change the attention heads and so we can
ask you know well i'll get to that in a
second yeah so there's a table
summarizing that um unfortunately this
this approach completely breaks down
once you have mlp layers mlp layers you
know now you have have these
non-linearities and so you don't get
this property where your model is mostly
linear and you can you can just look at
a matrix but if you're working with only
attention only transformers this is a
very nice way to think about effects
okay so recall that one that you're
intentionally transformers don't undergo
this phase change that we talked about
in the beginning like right now we're on
a hunt we're trying to go and answer
this mystery of how what the hell is
going on in that phase change where
models suddenly get good at in context
learning um we want to answer that and
one layer attention only transformers
don't undergo that phase change but two
layer attenuation transformers do so
we'd like to know what's different about
two layer attention only transformers
um
okay well so in our in our previous when
we're dealing with one layer attention
transformers we're able to go and
rewrite them in this
this form and it gave us a lot of struct
ability to go and understand the model
because we could go and say well you
know this is bi-grams and then each one
of these is looking somewhere and we
have this matrix that describes how it
affects things and
and yeah so that gave us a lot of a lot
of ability to think about this thing
these things and we we can also just
write in this factored form where we
have the embedding and then we have the
attention heads and then we have the
unembedding
okay well
um
oh and for simplicity we often go and
write wov for wowv because they always
come together it's always the case like
it's it's in some sense an illusion that
w o and wv are different matrices
they're just one low rank matrix they're
never they're they're always used
together and similarly w q and w k it's
sort of an illusion that they're they're
different matrices um they're they're
always just used together and and keys
and queries are just sort of they're
just an artifact of this of these low
rank matrices
so in any case it's useful to go and
write those together
um okay great so um a two-layer
attention only transformer what we do is
we we go through the embedding matrix
then we go through the layer one
attention heads then we go through the
layer two attenuates
and then we go through the unembedding
and for the the attention is we always
have this identity as well which
corresponds just going down the residual
string so we can
uh go down the residual stream or we can
go through an attention head
next step we can also go down the
residual stream or we can go through an
attention head
um and there's this useful identity uh
the mixed product identity that um any
tensor product or or other ways of
interpreting this um obey which is that
if you have an attention head
um and we have say you know we have the
weights and the attention pattern and
the wov matrix and the attention pattern
the attention patterns multiply together
and the ov circuits multiply together
um and they behave nicely okay great so
and we can just expand out that equation
we can just take that big product we had
at the beginning we just expanded out
and we get three different kinds of
terms so one thing we do is we get this
this path that just goes directly
through the residual stream where we
embed and unembed and that's going to
want to represent some bigram statistics
um then we get things that look like
the attention head terms that we had
previously
and finally
we get these terms that correspond to
going through two attention heads
and
now it's worth noting that these terms
are not actually the same as they're
because the attention head uh the
attention patterns in the next in the
second layer can be computed from the
outputs of the first layer there those
are also going to be more expressive but
at a high level you can think of there
as being these three different kinds of
terms and we sometimes call these terms
virtual attention nets because they they
don't exist in the sun like they aren't
sort of explicitly represented in the
model but um they in fact you know they
have an attention pattern they have no
circuit they're sort of in almost all
functional ways like a tiny little
attention head and there's exponentially
many of them
um
it turns out they're not going to be
that important in this model but in
other models they can be important
um right so one one thing that i said it
allows us to think about attention in a
really principled way we don't have to
go and think about um
you know i think there's like people
people look at attention patterns all
the time and i think a concern you could
have is well you know
there's multiple attention patterns like
you know the information that's been
moved by one intention it might have
been moved there by another attention
ahead and not originally there it might
still be moved somewhere else um but in
fact this gives us a way to avoid all
those concerns and just think about
things in a single principled way
um okay in any case um an important
question to ask is how important are
these different terms well we could
study all of them how important are they
um
and it turns out um you can just
there's an algorithm you can use where
you knock out attention
knock out these terms and you go and you
ask how important are they
um and the it turns out the by far the
most important thing is these individual
attention head terms in this model far
by far the most important thing the
virtual tension heads basically
don't matter that much
they only have an effect of 0.3 not
using to be the above ones and the
bigrams are still pretty useful so if we
want to try it on channel's model we
should probably go and focus our
attention on you know the virtual
attention heads are not going to be the
best way to go in and go in our uh focus
our attention especially since there's
there's a lot of them there's 124 of
them for 0.3 knots it's very little that
you would understand for prosthetic one
of those terms
so the thing that we probably want to do
we know that these are bigram statistics
so what we really want to do is we want
to
understand
the
the individual tension head terms
um this is the algorithm i'm going to
skip over it for time
we can ignore that term because it's
small
um
and it turns out also that the layer two
attention heads are doing way more than
layer one attention so that's that's not
that surprising like the layer two
intense are more expressive because they
can use the layer one attention to
construct their attention patterns
okay so uh if we could just go and
understand the layer two attention heads
we probably understand a lot of what's
going on in this model
um
and the trick is that the attention
heads are now constructed from the
previous layer rather than just from the
tokens so this is still the same but the
attention head the attention pattern is
more more complex and if you write it
out you get this complex equation that
says you know you embed the tokens then
you're going to shuffle things around
using the attention edits for the keys
then you multiply by w uk then you
multiply shuffle things around again for
the queries and then you go and multiply
by the embedding again because they were
embedded and then you get back to the
tokens um
uh
but let's actually look at them so
uh one thing that's remember that when
we see positive eigenvalues in the ob
circuit we're doing copying so one thing
we can say is well 7 out of 12 and in
fact the ones with the largest
eigenvalues um are doing coffeeing so we
still have a lot of attention they're
doing copying
um
and yeah the qk circuit so one one thing
you could do is you could try to
understand things in terms of this more
complex qk equation you could also just
try to understand what the attention
patterns are doing empirically so let's
look at one of these copying ones
um i've given it the first paragraph of
harry potter and we can just look at
where it attends
and something really happened
interesting happens so almost all the
time
we just attend back to
the first token we have this this
special token at the beginning of the
sequence
and we usually think of that as just
being um a null attention operation it's
a way for it to not do anything in fact
if you if you look the value vector is
basically zero it's just not copying any
information from that
um
but when whenever we see repeated text
something interesting happens so when we
get to mr
tries to look at and it's a little bit
weak then we get to d
and it tends to errors
that's interesting
and then we get to ers
and it tends to lean
um and so it's not attending to
the same token it's attending to the
same token
shifted one forward
well that's really interesting and
there's actually a lot of attention nets
that are doing this so here we have one
where now we hit the potter's pot and we
attend deters maybe that's the same
tension i don't remember when i was
constructing this example
um it turns out this is a super common
thing so you you go and you you look for
the previous example you shift one
forward and you're like okay well last
time i solved this this is what happened
probably the same thing's gonna happen
um and we can we can go and look at the
effect that the attention head has on
the logits most of the time it's not
affecting things but in these cases it's
able to go and predict when it's doing
us this thing of going and looking
forward to go and predict the next token
um so we call this an induction an
induction head looks for the previous
copy looks forward and says ah probably
the same thing that happened last time
it's gonna happen you can think of this
as being a nearest neighbor's it's like
an in-context nearest neighbor's
algorithm it's going and searching
through your context finding similar
things and then predicting that's what's
gonna happen next
um
the way that these actually work is uh i
mean there's actually two ways but in a
model that uses rotary attention or
something like this you only only have
one
and
you shift your key first you have
an earlier attention head shifts your
key forward once you you like take the
value of the previous token and you
embed it in your present token
and then you have your query and your
key go and look
at
uh
yeah try to go and match so you look for
the same thing
um and then you go and you predict that
whatever you saw is going to be the next
token so that's the the high-level
algorithm um sometimes you can do clever
things where actually it'll care about
multiple earlier tokens and it'll look
for like short phrases and so on so
induction heads can really vary in in
how much they of the previous context
they care about or what aspects of the
previous context they care about but
this general trick of looking for the
same thing shift forward predict that is
what induction has been
um lots of examples of this
and the cool thing is you can now
you can use the qk eigenvalues to
characterize this you can say well you
know we we're looking for the same thing
shifted by one but looking for the same
thing if you expand through the
attention notes in the right way that'll
work out
um and we're copying and so an induction
head is one which has both positive ov
eigenvalues and also positive qk
eigenvalues
um and so you can just put that on a
plot and you have your induction heads
in the corner see
here ov eigen values your qk eigenvalues
i think actually ov is this axis qk is
this one access doesn't matter um and in
the corner you have your your icon
values
or your um your induction heads
um yeah and so this seems to be uh well
okay we now have a natural hypothesis
the hypothesis is the way that that
phase change we're seeing the phase
changes this is the discovery of these
induction heads that would be um the
hypothesis uh and these are way more
effective than regular you know than
this first algorithm we had which was
just sort of blindly copy things
wherever it could be plausible now we
can go and like actually recognize
patterns and look at what happened and
break that similar things are going to
happen again that's a way better
algorithm
um
yeah so there's other attention heads
that are doing more local things i'm
gonna go and skip over that and return
to our mystery because i am running out
of time i have five more minutes okay so
what what is going on with this in
context learning well now now we've
hypothesis let's check it um so we think
it might be induction heads
um
and there's a few reasons we believe
this so one thing is going to be that
inductive uh induction heads
well okay i'll just go over to the other
so one thing you can do is you can just
ablate the attention ends
and it turns it um you can color here we
have attention heads colored by how much
they are in induction head
and this is the start of the bump this
is the end of the bump here
and we can see that they first of all
induction heads are forming like
previously we didn't have induction
heads here now they're just starting to
form here and then we have really
intense induction heads here and here
and the attention heads where if you
ablate them and you get
a uh
you get a a loss and so we're we're
lucky not lost but this this meta
learning score the difference between or
in context learning store the the
difference between the 500th token and
the 50th token
and that's all explained by induction
heads
now we actually have one induction head
that doesn't contribute to it actually
it does the opposite so that's kind of
interesting uh maybe it's doing
something shorter shorter distance um
and there's also this interesting thing
where like they all rush to be induction
heads and then they they discover only
only a few went out in the end so
there's some interesting dynamics going
on there but it really seems like in
these small models
all of in context learning is explained
by these induction hats
um okay
what about large models well in large
models it's going to be harder to go and
ask this but one thing you can do is you
can ask okay you know
we can look at our uh our induction or
our in-context learning score over time
we get this sharp phase change oh look
induction heads form at exactly the same
point in time
so that's only correlational evidence
but it's pretty suggestive correlational
evidence even especially given that we
have an obvious you know like the
obvious the fact that induction heads
should have is is this um i guess it
could be that there's other mechanisms
being discovered at the same time in
large models but it has to be in a very
small window
so
really suggest the thing that's driving
that change is in context learning
um okay so
uh
obviously induction heads can go and
copy text but a question you might ask
is you know can they can they do
translation like there's all these
amazing things that models can do that
it's not obvious and you know in context
learning um or this sort of copying
mechanism could do so i just want to
very quickly
um
look at a few fun examples
so here we have
um
an attention pattern
oh i guess i need to open lexus scopes
hmm let me try doing that again
sorry i should have thought this through
a bit more before this talk
um
chris could you zoom in a little please
yeah yeah thank you
um
okay i'm not my french isn't that great
but
um my name is christopher i'm from
canada
um what we can do here is we can look at
where this attention head attends as we
go and we do this and
um it'll become especially clear on the
second sentence so here we're on the
period
and we tend to shift
now we're on
um and jus is i in french okay now we're
on the eye and we attend to speed
uh now we're on the am and we are trends
to do which is from and then from to
canada
and so we're doing a cross-lingual
induction head which we can use for
translation um and indeed if you look at
examples this is this is where it seems
to you know it seems to be a major
driving force in the model's ability to
go um and correctly do translation
another fun example is
um i think maybe maybe the most
impressive thing about in context
learning to me has been the model's
ability to go and learn arbitrary
functions like you can just show the
model a function it can start mimicking
that function well okay
yes yeah so do these induction heads
only do kind of a look ahead copy or
like can they also do some sort of like
a complex
uh structure recognition
yeah yeah so they can they can both use
a larger context previous context and
they can copy more abstract things so
like the translation one is showing you
that they can copy rather than the
literal token a translated version so
it's what i call a soft induction head
um and yeah you can you can have them
copy similar words you can have them
look at longer contexts it can look for
more structural things um
the way that we usually characterize
them is is whether in in large models
just whether they empirically behave
like an induction head so the the the
bound the definition gets a little bit
blurry when you try to encompass these
more this sort of blurry a blurry
boundary um but yeah there seem to be a
lot of attention heads that are doing
sort of more and more abstract versions
and yeah my my favorite version is this
one that i'm about to show you which is
um used let's isolate a single one of
these which can do pattern recognition
so it can learn functions in the context
and learn how to do it so i've just made
up a nonsense function here um
we're going to encode one binary
variable with a choice of whether to do
a color or a month as the first word
then
we're gonna so we have green or june
here
um let's zoom in more
so we have color or month
and animal or fruit and then we have to
map it to either true or false
so that's our goal and it's going to be
an xor so we have a binary variable
represented in this way we do an xor
i'm
pretty confident this was never in the
training set because i just made it up
and it seems like a nonsense problem
um okay so then we can go and ask you
know can the model go and push that well
it can and it uses induction heads to do
it and what we can do is we can look at
the so we look at a colon where it's
going to go and try and predict the next
word
and for instance here
um we have april dog so it's a month and
then an animal and it should be true
and what it does is it looks for a
previous previous cases where there was
an animal
a month and then an animal especially
one where the month was the same and
goes and looks and says that it's true
and so the model can go and learn learn
a function a completely arbitrary
function
by going and doing this kind of pattern
recognition
induction head
and this to me made it a lot more
plausible but these models actually
can do
can do in context learning like the
generality of all these amazing things
we see these large language models do um
uh can be explained by inductionists we
don't know that it could be that there's
other things going on um it's very
possible that there's lots of other
things going on um but it seems seems a
lot more plausible to me than it did
when when we started
i'm conscious that i am actually over
time i mean just quickly go through
these last few slides yeah so i think
thinking that this is like an in context
in your sneakers i think is a really
useful way to think about this um other
things could absolutely be contributing
um this might explain why uh
transformers do in-context learning uh
over long contacts better than uh lstms
and lstm can't do this because it's it's
not linear in the amount of compute it
needs it's like quadratic or n log n if
it was really clever
um so transformers are lstm is
impossible to do this transformers um do
do this and actually they diverge at the
same point but if you if you look well
i can go into this in more detail after
if you want um
there's a really nice paper by marcus
hutter explaining trying to predict and
explain why we observe scaling laws and
models it's worth noting that the
arguments in this paper go exactly
through to uh this example this theory
in fact they sort of work better for the
the case of thinking about these this in
context learning with with essentially a
nearest neighbor's algorithm um than
they do in in the regular case so
um yeah uh i'm happy to answer questions
i can go into as much detail as people
want about any of this and i can also if
you send me an email sending more
information about all this um and
uh yeah and you know again this this
work is not yet published and you don't
have to keep it secret but um you know
just if you could be thoughtful about
the fact that um it's unpublished work
and probably a month or two away from
coming out um i'd be really grateful for
that uh thank you so much for your time
yeah thanks a lot chris this was a great
talk
um so i'll just open up like some
general questions and then we can do
like a round of questions from the
students
so i was very excited to know like so
what is the
like the line of work that you're
currently working on is it like
extending this uh so what do you think
is like the next things you try to do to
make it more independable what are the
next yeah
i mean i want to just reverse engineer
language models i want to figure out the
entirety of what's going on in these
language models
um
and uh
you know like
one thing that we totally don't
understand is
mlp layers um more we understand
something about them um but we we don't
really understand mlp layers very well
uh there's a lot of stuff going on in
large models that we don't understand i
want to know how models do arithmetic um
i want to know um another thing that i'm
very interested in is what's going on
when you have multiple speakers the
model can clearly represent like it has
it has like a basic theory of mind
multiple speakers in a dialogue i
understand what's going on with that um
but honestly there's just so much we
don't understand um it's really it's
sort of hard to answer the question
because there's just so much to to
figure out um and we have a lot of
different threads of research and doing
this but um yeah and
uh the interpreted team at anthropic is
just sort of
has a bunch of threads trying to go and
figure out what's going on inside these
models and sort of a similar flavor to
this of just trying to figure out how do
the parameters actually encode
algorithms and can we reverse engineer
those into into meaningful computer
programs that we can we can understand
well
uh another question that is like so you
were talking about like how
like the transformers are trying to do
metal learning inherently so it's like
and you already spent a lot of time
talking about like uh the induction hats
and like that was like interesting but
like can you formalize the sort of metal
learning algorithm they might be
learning is it like possible to say like
oh maybe this is a sort of like uh like
internal algorithm that's going that's
making them like good metal learners or
something like that
i don't know i mean i think i think so i
think that there's roughly two
algorithms one is this algorithm we saw
in the one layer model and we see it in
other models too especially early on
which is just you know try to copy you
know you saw a word probably a similar
word is going to happen uh later um look
for places that it might fit in and
increase the probability so that's
that's one thing that we see and the
other thing we see is uh induction heads
which you can just summarize as as in
context nearest neighbors basically um
and it seems you know possibly there's
other things but it seems like those two
algorithms um and you know the specific
instantiations that we are looking at uh
seem to be what's driving in context
learning that would be my present theory
yeah sounds very interesting
um yeah okay um so let's open like a
round of first two questions so yeah
feel free to go ahead
for those questions
you